who's going to win the Super Bowl Eagles
or the Chiefs and so with that being
said Adam since you brought this up this
was your suggestion because our audience
loves sports tell us yeah my idea to
cover the Super Bowl yeah that's not a
big deal it's just the Super Bowl
um we're talking about the best team in
the AFC the Kansas City Chiefs and the
best team in the NFC Philadelphia Eagles
going to head to head I think
Philadelphia is favored by one and a
half points Philly the Eagles one and a
half two points I'm gonna check right
now and uh I don't know I I'm gonna lean
on Philly I think Mahomes a little hurt
he just won MVP I don't think there's a
good case for when you win MVP then you
win the Super Bowl with super MVP so I
think that that Philly is gonna eke it
out by a couple points Pat let me
explain something to you I don't know if
you guys saw the last game with KFC
Kentucky Fried Chicken I fall
um guess what the script has already
been written Patrick Mahomes who's his
biggest who's he sponsored who's the
sponsor Patrick Mahomes who's his
biggest uh Allstate oh State Farm State
Farm guess where the game Guess What
stadium they're playing in
State Farm
Chiefs win by a touchdown one 100 that's
right it's already written homie Insider
information Patrick it's been written
you saw the horrible calls in the last
game yeah it's come on who's winning it
who's winning good time 31-27 Philly and
Mahomes is coming back making it close
if there's another three minutes in the
game he wins it oh man so here's here's
what I think I think Billy's going to
get out in front and I think you're
gonna so we got two Phillies we got one
KFC pbd I'm gonna do what the better did
yesterday I'm gonna go with the Bengals
I think
and we'll give you eight and a half
eight and a half what about 10 million
no I think listen I like the love the
feistiness of Mahomes okay obviously I
was cheering for Joe burrow to beat him
because I'm a burrow guy I love bro I
think burro is a chip on the shoulder
away from whooping on everybody for a
decade if he can get that chip on the
shoulder but the way Mahomes plays
Mahomes gives me the vibe of Kobe MJ the
attitude the energy he's got that Brady
angry wants to beat you like his eyes
are like this middle of the game they're
down a touchdown he's not afraid he's
staying solid like it's a very very
unique characteristic that he has Eagles
have an incredible defense uh I love the
fact how poised their quarterback is
but I have a feeling mom's gonna win a
second Super Bowl because Mahomes got
one target I think he's going after
Brady uh you know the other day when
Brady announced his retirement Mahomes
posted on the bottom in the comments
section the goat which was great to see
Mahomes give him a shout out of the
golden but you're seeing the other day
when LeBron passed Kareem Abdul-Jabbar
in points and Shaq was asking uh Lebron
the question so say so tell me a young
brother yeah you know so what do you
think is going to be the good he says
man I see myself as the greatest player
of all time I've seen like LeBron said
this all right LeBron sees himself as
the greatest player of all time I think
he's the second greatest player of all
time but LeBron sees himself as the
greatest player of all time I think
Mahomes wants to prove a point and what
better year for Mahomes to win it than
the year Brady retired wow you got to
win the championship
I don't know it's a great show two and
two so we have to have our friend Malik
hey Malik rob you gotta break this time
so there's a Super Bowl this weekend
so we'll see what happens so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
foreign